and then
thank you I finally made it I've been
waiting at the Santa Monica Auditorium
that's where they told me away but I
would like to congratulate the Academy
on a brilliant show tonight it had it
had almost everything
but it was their fault I feel like a
third smothers brother though I've never
been on this late in the show he's still
in primetime I shaved twice waiting in
the wings and that's not easy shaving a
green face but I want to tell you that
I've been trying to get on before this
because I didn't want to meet myself on
The Late Show this is the beautiful
beautiful night and I want to Ted this
is the first Academy Award that I have
an M seed in about four years and I just
stopped by to see how I wasn't doing
it's really great it's a great hit in
fact I understand David Merrick is
already planning to take it on the road
now can you imagine the lying tuxedo
instead of our usual white tie and Tails
I knew the riffraff would get in sooner
or later that's a blow to me you know
because I'm Madoff manju Toluca Lake
that guy was voted one of America's best
dressed men by the cast of hair
but it's been a beautiful show I've been
watching it backstage from my dressing
room I like to sneer in private I'm
kidding I'm not bitter although I'll
admit through in the last hour I didn't
care whether there was an earthquake or
not by the way we can expect that
earthquake any minute
just remember Charlton Heston wasn't
nominated in this a beautiful setting
with all the lights and the mirrors and
the whole thing you we're all working in
a Ross Hunter movie now it's a beautiful
place to Music Center buff Chandler's
rumpus room
and there's going to be there's going to
be another presentation in the basement
for the underground movies
I have never seen so many stars they're
all here tonight they even asked Jack
Benny to drive down here but it takes
more than a gallon of gas but this is it
the industry is big night you can feel
the electricity in this room
I just felt a spark leap from my Dacron
shorts to my polyester socks what
tension here it is the audience it's
curious yellow and nominees I'll never
forgive Ron Moody he was nominated for
doing the story of my life and I can't
believe the nominating Romeo and Juliet
is Best Picture it's such an obvious
steal from West Side Story Oliver is the
story of an honest country boy who comes
to the city and gets corrupted by some
singing thieves reminds me of my career
with crosby pictures have been pretty
wild this year haven't they
Oscar is more naked than usual I don't
believe some of those pictures like
candy I had to see it three times to
believe it now they're doing things on
the screen today I wouldn't do in bed
even if I had the chance but I want to
tell you
there are so many they're giving by the
way they're giving President Nixon the
best acting performance outside the
industry award we're spending two whole
days smiling at general to God you know
I really wasn't supposed to be on the
show this year then Greg and Gaara
called me last week to tell me that the
Jean Hersholt award had been voted to
Martha Raye and they asked me if I'd
present it to her and I tell you I'm
delighted to do it
Martha Raye yes I feel like I want to
join the world in the claiming her
contributions of the morale of our
fighting men you know a lot of people in
our business of visited Vietnam but
she's the only one I know who has a
billboard on the Ho Chi Minh Trail she's
been there and back five times she's
played hillside foxholes she's played
perimeter outposts radar bases PT boats
the Highlands and the Delta swamps she's
played every kind of hospital from feel
bases with standing room only to 500 bed
houses of horror and she's been wounded
by enemy gunfire she knows what they
want songs laughs as only she can do it
such charge and excitement on stage that
would thrill even the spying Viet Cong
but she didn't do it free she didn't do
it without a reward tonight she's earned
the Jean Hersholt award Nats as it
should be a reward for great
humanitarian service to our country and
its people but even more important she's
earned the love and respect and the
undying admiration of every home sick
kid in uniform who so desperately seeks
to touch a feel a moment of home it is
with this in mind we paid tribute to a
great gal a great lady a great woman our
colonel Maggie of the boondocks miss
Martha Raye right
Martha I know that you probably don't
realize you're the first woman to ever
receive the Jean Hersholt award yes sir
I do realize I do realize it I'm still
nervous I know but your honor I'm sorry
what Academy ladies and gentlemen I do a
beautiful legend Bob Hope this is the
most beautiful honorable wonderful
exciting day of my life
stateside and on behalf of all of our
troops myself I promise you I shall try
for for the rest of my life to really
deserve and be worthy of this
magnificent honor bestowed upon me god
bless you thank you